[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
joe person who broke the story yesterday
that uh cam was going to come back joe
covers the panthers for the athletic
joins us on the program how much of a
surprise was this joe
yeah dan it it was pretty surprising
just because you know matt rule got here
in january of 2020.
he and dave tepper
and at the time marty herney was the gm
they made the decision
that they were going to move on from cam
newton they there were concerns
mostly about his throwing shoulder he'd
had the two shoulder surgeries
he did not look as you mentioned like
the 2015 cam
and
and and the other piece of this too is
here was matt rule coming in they were
going to turn over the whole roster go
young
they drafted seven defensive players
and i think
and cam has said this publicly he felt
like rule was a little intimidated by
his sort of big persona which we've all
seen and i just don't think it was a
good fit at that time will it be a good
fit now i don't know but but they had to
do something like even before darnold's
injury
they were getting really i mean bottom
of the league type quarterback play and
this is a team that still is holding out
hope for a playoff berth
i'm just trying to figure out i mean
they botched this
if you look back on this joe i mean
teddy bridgewater who i do like then you
know you pay him whatever 35 million you
trade for darnold you guarantee the you
know the contract for next year you pass
on justin fields and then who comes to
the rescue but the artist formerly known
as superman here um
how good is the team anyway offensively
if i'm plugging in cam newton now
given pros and cons
uh how good is the offense
well they just got christian mccaffrey
back last week as you know that helps
that helps a lot
uh they have some wide receivers that
are pretty good in dj more robbie
anderson has struggled with sam darnold
i think sam darnold
i think it was losing confidence in
anderson but also sometimes just not
seeing him and not seeing the field and
the open receivers so the problem that
cam newton is going to find is the same
one that darnold faced as well the
offensive line is not good and they're
down to they're down to two week one
starters left healthy
they're having to kind of move guys
around up front darnold and and
but here's the thing
cam newton he's seen that before i mean
he he is a professional
and not that he wants to stand in there
and take it but he is not going to get
happy feet which is what we've seen from
sam darnold for about the past month
here in charlotte okay but you've
guaranteed sam darnold's contract for
next year i think it's what 19 million
dollars
what yeah is this is this a victory lap
for cam as a way of saying hey we did
you wrong and come on back and let's see
if we have any magic here is there
is there any let's open up the scrapbook
and bring cam back like
sentimental journey here or is this just
strictly football
i think if you talk to matt rule and
general manager scott fitter it's a
football decision i think ownership
david tepper has seen the fan base i
mean last week dan there were a ton of
patriots fans in bank of america stadium
they've had other games where the eagles
filled up you know season ticket holders
are selling their seats
uh apathy sets in that's like the worst
kind of deal for an nfl owner
um cam will change that immediately i
mean that they're next week the first
home game is against ron rivera and
washington
the guy who brought cam in number one in
2011.
so i think yeah
ownership david tepper realizes he
needed some juice
pj walker great guy great athlete that
wasn't going to cut it i mean there were
going to be a lot of empty seats here
over the last two months of the season
great to talk to you joe congratulations
on breaking the story thanks for joining
us
thanks for having me dan all right joe
person he uh covers carolina panthers
for the athletic and uh he broke this
story yesterday
cam newton coming back to the carolina
panthers